[Music]
yesterday for the first time in over 40
years the New York City Marathon was
canceled yeah 40,000 runners were
expected to compete quite a few were
very upset when the event was cancelled
yeah damn right I'm upset I'm sorry are
you a fan of the marathon fan I was
going to run and I'm a hundred percent
positive I was gonna win okay no offense
but you don't look like a typical
marathoner oh why cuz I'm not some
skinny bad foot guy from Kenya I trained
my ass off for this marathon you trained
every morning I start with the
high-protein meatball parmesan sandwich
that does not sound very healthy it's
not weight bread then I head over to
Macy's and run up the down escalator
until security throws me out and if that
wasn't enough I haven't had sex you
haven't had sex not for 23 years
really none only furious heroic bouts of
masturbation
cause that's what serious athletes do as
Troy Polamalu for God's sake if they
cancelled the marathon where do you get
the mylar tape in the metal oh so now a
guy can't get drunk and buy a cape and
metal on eBay without getting the third
degree from you
you go to hell O'Brien I'm out of here
all right
best of luck with next year's marathon
oh my
[Music]
1980 tragic I don't feel well I'll grant
you okay fine
oh he's gone again alright he's not he's
not that that's a terrible paramedic
right now is that all you do is answer
that
1987 yeah he looks awful for 1987 he's
lived a hard life a lot of meatballs all
right well at least now he's really
really dead I hope Bill Murray
I just wanted to see if we could get him
to come up again that's all